Heroes
That's something the world sorely needs.
Avengers.
I am the inevitable.
There will always be more
to finish my work.
This is just the beginning.
She's destroying every place I call home
and taking powers from this.
If I don't fix this,
it will be the end of everything.
You got this?
I'm asking
for one last fight.
there's a different reality
leading into our year here
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my brand new Marvels trailer.
There's a bunch of new footage
and a brand new scene of Thanos.
That's right.
There's a brand new scene with Thanos that
we have not heard before from the time around.
Avengers Endgame. I'll explain
what's going on with that.
there were like two or 3 hours worth of Avengers
Endgame In Avengers Infinity War,
they went up deleting from those movies
just because the movies got so big.
some of you also probably spotted
the X-Men teaser
in one of the trailers here too,
where they're talking about the incursions.
Like literally they use the what comes next
with the fade out on the X line specifically,
meaning that there is some X-Men stuff
happening during the movie,
which I'll talk about later in the video.
there's this a bunch of scenes that explain
more about what's going on with Miss Marvel's
two different Bangles and them teasing
what's happening in the next phase of Marvel.
Like the next couple of movies.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I've been doing that
Loki Blu-Ray giveaway of my Loki videos.
I'll just continue that on this.
So all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and post all your theories
about what's going on in the movie.
really big warning, too.
There's like a weird spammer
going around the comments of my videos
and a lot of other people's videos
for big channels,
basically trying to get people to message them
on like Telegram and other weird things,
saying that they have some giveaway
that they one that is not me.
I'll never ask anybody in any of the comments
to message me on some other social media network
or anything like that.
Hopefully YouTube will fix the problem.
but the brand new seen a Thanos in
this is him saying that they'll always be more
to finish my work in addition
to a bunch of other scenes that we did
see in the theater for Avengers Endgame with him
saying I am Inevitable with Iron Man
joining the Infinity Stones
and snapping the Infinity gantlet.
they've been including a bunch of Avengers
endgame footage in the last couple of Marvels
trailers.
It's just this particular Thanos scene
that they include in This is like brand new.
Never before heard.
and I believe it's part of a deleted scene
from Avengers Endgame.
Like I said, they're like 6 hours
worth of that movie that they cut out
just because it got way too long,
deleted scenes, a bunch of alternate endings.
I did a bunch of videos for all of those
a few years ago when Avengers Endgame
came out in theaters.
They only posted
a few of the deleted scenes online,
but I'll post links for all those scenes
in the description below.
it's almost like there were two versions
of Avengers Endgame, maybe
like four versions that they filmed,
and we only saw one of them in theaters.
in, I believe the scene of him
talking about others being out there to finish
his work was from
this part of the final battle where Iron Man,
Captain America and Thor start to fight him.
But this is before Doctor Strange and Wang
show up to Portal everyone to the battlefield.
So it's just the four of them
getting ready to square off and fight.
there was meant to be a completely alternate
version of this ending to the movie.
Like big alternate ending,
as you would expect, like the actual fight
went down in a very different way.
Originally what was going to happen
is that Thanos from 2014 was going to kill
all the Avengers in his original 2014
time when he learned what was really going on.
then, after killing all those Avengers
in that time period,
he comes forward to the future
to fight them in the final battle,
showing up by throwing Captain America's severed
head at their feet, seeing Captain America
react to his dead head, part of the reason
for them doing things this way is that
for a lot of the production of the movie, like,
well, things were actually being filmed.
There was a lot of discussion about them wanting
to kill off all of the original six Avengers,
but by the time they got close to finishing
the movie, they got a little bit shy
about that, like, No, maybe
we don't want to kill every single one of them.
So this scene was sort of a compromise
between those two ideas,
like they had their cake and eat it, too,
because he killed The Avengers in the past,
then came forward to the future,
to fight these versions of the characters
and the reason why Killing The Avengers
in the past didn't erase these versions
from existence in the Final Battle is because
of the way time travel works in the MCU.
So you have to remember changing the past
doesn't change your original future.
It only creates a new nexus.
Been branching out
from that timeline like a totally new timeline
which they covered in the Loki series.
so after Thanos would have killed
all The Avengers in 2014, there would have been
a new branch timeline out there
where there were no Avengers anymore.
But the original sacred timeline version of them
didn't change in this final battle.
Like things still went down
this way, up to this moment.
then they have their brief conversation
where they start to square off and they have
the scene of him talking about there
being others out there that will finish his work
it it was meant to build on the concept
that they were teasing the other major villains
that Marvel was going to introduce in Marvel
Phase four or Phase five basics.
The next saga after that, like Kang, The Conquer
The Council of Kangs, just in general.
It was also meant to tease villains
that Marvel hadn't
figured out yet, like they didn't know exactly
when they were going to do like Galactus.
They knew at the time.
Eventually they do a version of Galactus,
a Nihilist, the Celestials,
but they weren't
sure exactly when they were going to do those.
so they just wanted a generic teaser for those,
like the way they tease all the future movies
in successive Avengers movies,
it was basically Thanos saying that
even if the Avengers were able to stop him
today, kill him, prevent him
from snapping the Infinity gantlet again,
there would always be another villain
more powerful than him,
who would come along and balance the universe.
there's no way that they'd always be able
to stop the next villain around the corner.
So this is also meant to build on
that Iron Man teaser.
You mess with time, it tends to mess back
now in present day.
That's
something that they're paying off with Avengers
five in the Council of Kangs coming for them
because the Avengers are quote unquote
messing with time, messing with the multiverse.
so in the trailer they're using that
Thanos reference like the next villain
around the corner to try and balance
the universe being a reference to Dar
Ben, the leader of the Kree in present day,
who's using Ms.
Marvel's other bangle, which they're finally
confirming are based on the Kree mega
bands and quasars
Quantum bands, two completely different things,
but they're sort of combining those ideas
in the MCU the Kree Naga bands are powered
by the negative zone, which is the big Fantastic
four thing in the Quantum.
Bands of Quasar are powered by the quantum
realm.
are couple moments during the last few marvels
trailers that do a better job at showing off
some of the other powers of the Bangles,
like Darb, Ben is using hers
in a different way than Ms.. Marvel uses hers.
But just to be clear,
they're both the exact same type of bangle.
The two bangles don't have different abilities.
it is that Ms..
Marvel also has her different mutant powers.
On top of that, she came up with her own way
of using her bangle than Dar Ben did with hers.
part of the idea is that Da
Ben comes into the movie knowing way more
about what the Bangles actually are
and how to use their full power.
you have to remember that the Marvels movie
takes place literally right after the Ms..
Marvel series ends.
So, like, she's just gotten the bangle.
She has barely
any idea of how it actually works.
She knows that it's special.
She can make constructs with it.
But part of the idea is that her
mutant powers also influence
that should probably get a much bigger info dump
on what the Bangles actually are
and how to actually use them during the movie.
But notice in the trailers, Darb
Ben is using her bangle in combination
with one of the accuser core hammers.
It's just like running the accuser's hammer
to open portals across space
that allow her to steal resources from planets
friendly to Captain Marvel
and bring the resources decree worlds
that need them they're meant to start the movie
at a low point for their race
that the Kree race is on the verge of dying out.
They're losing resources
because Captain Marvel spent the last 30 years
basically trying to cripple their society
across the galaxy,
cripple their military strength, cripple
their industrial capacity.
that's why they hate her so much.
When the movie picks up, da.
Ben then finds the other Bengal and uses it
to steal resources from other planets
to help them survive.
So she's kind of balancing, quote unquote,
the universe, but balancing it towards the Kree.
the other power that they show off in
the trailer is the Bengal
gives her the ability to absorb
Captain Marvel's blast.
There's a recent trailer
with a fight scene where she taunts are saying
that her attacks only make da Ben stronger.
That was what she was talking about.
So Captain Marvel can blast her all she wants
and it'll just literally make her more powerful.
They're basically trying to say that Captain
Marvel can't beat her in combat this way.
Like she won't be able to solve this problem
by punching it away.
I haven't seen the movie yet.
But the early theory is this is going to be
one of those movies, unlike Avengers Endgame,
that will end with them having to talk it out
like Brothers, so to speak, instead of fighting,
even though it's a bunch of women,
like they won't end the movie Killing Da Ben.
They'll in the movie with some truce
and make arrangements that will help the Kree
race survive and then hostilities
between them in the squirrel's.
so that their relationship going forward
is a little bit more like Goku and Vegeta.
Like they're not best of friends,
but they're also not bitter, bitter enemies
that was what that ending scene
in the Secret Invasion series was all about.
Like they were meant to tease the Marvels
movie, The Peace Summit.
He was heading to is something they're going
to cover during the Marvels there's
also a bunch of brand new footage
of Monica Rambeau in the recent trailers
talking about another reality
that's starting to bleed into their reality.
So this gets back to the whole Avengers
five Kang
Dynasty, Avengers
six Secret Wars of it all with the Incursions.
this movie is supposed to show us
an actual incursion going down
like they've been talking
about in previous movies.
Now we're finally actually going to see it
go down.
apparently she's supposed to get trapped
in this other reality.
And it's meant to be like a universe
with X-Men characters teasing Deadpool three.
And there's some kind of Deadpool
three Post-Credits scene they literally tease
X-Men stuff here in the actual trailer because
when they're transitioning what comes next?
It fades out on the X line like, yeah, we're
definitely doing some X-Men stuff in this movie.
Coincidence? I think not.
I believe it's also
meant to be a universe where her mother,
Maria Rambo, became Captain Marvel.
So she gets to see her mother again
because the main universe version of her
mother died during the five year Time's up.
We saw that go down during Wandavision like
she got snapped back after her mother had died.
So essentially she didn't get to say goodbye
to her mother and she'll get to see her again
at the end of this movie,
or a version of her mother.
not the one from the A38 universe, because
they killed that version of Captain Marvel.
Generally, there's also a lot more Avengers
references in the last couple of Marvels
trailers, too, because they want to tease
that they're eventually going
to put together that new Avengers team,
I believe were meant to get a teaser for that
at some point during Captain America four,
but I don't think
the team will actually come together
till like Marvel Phase six.
there's a lot of movies
that Marvel has not announced for Marvel
Phase six yet,
like the next couple of years, Kevin Feige.
He's got a little shy about announcing
future things
just because he doesn't want to have to announce
that they also got delayed.
So it's a little embarrassing for them
to announce like a big schedule
and then announce that it's been delayed
like six different times.
there's a bunch of other big stuff
coming up really soon too.
Like we have X-Men 97 episodes that's supposed
to come after the Echo series drops.
And I think we're going to get an echo trailer
at some point this week, maybe next week.
Like really, really soon.
Of course I'll do a video for that
because the biggest thing about that series
is that daredevil and kingpin are coming back in
a much bigger way than they did in Spider-Man,
No Way Home and during the Hawkeyes series.
So it's meant to be
sort of like a setup for Daredevil Born Again,
which they completely reworked.
Now, the show runner from The Punisher
is actually doing Daredevil, born again
in a bunch of people from the Loki series.
So Kevin Feige
just stacked the deck for Daredevil born again.
I'm way more excited about that show now there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up Click here
for my brand new Loki Episode five and episode
six video and click here to learn about that
Quasar deleted scene during the Marvels movie
in a bunch of other Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!